The Joe Rogan Experience must one work
out every day isn't that last one
workout every day yeah one must work out
one must burn 500 calories in a workout
every single day seven days a week
365 days well 60. 30 days I'm already
expanding
so what isn't it is there a contest
about who can burn the most calories
we're not doing that because we go crazy
yeah the problem with contests is they
absorb your whole life yeah and
everybody except Ari has a family and
obligations and jobs and podcasts and
different things they have to do just we
did it one year the contest and it was
pretty obvious halfway in that we were
[ __ ]
because I remember you got behind and
then you just powered through and came
from behind with like some crazy
workouts well I was never really behind
I mean I might have been behind for like
a day
it was so in the beginning we were
trying to figure out how much we're
gonna burn
you know because we were using this my
zones thing so it's like you wear a
chest strap
and the chest strap gives you points uh
with the application for however many
minutes you are at eighty percent of
your max heart rate versus 90 of your
max Hardware like 90s two points 80s one
or something like that yeah and
Ari figured out that he could watch TV
while you were doing cardio so he
watched movies on an iPad while he's
doing cardio yeah and he ran up a big
number like 400 in a day we're like [ __ ]
that's a big number there was like two
movies yeah
and so then we really started getting
crazy
and then one day I did 1100 points I did
seven hours of cardio no [ __ ]
yeah mostly what running no mostly
elliptical machine because we watch
movies yeah so I watched John Wick like
50 times
I kept rewinding it to the scene in the
bath house where he kills everybody
it's just because it's so adrenaline
filled you can keep going yeah I watched
some fights I watched a bunch of [ __ ]
and it's like it just got too crazy yeah
we were losing our minds all right we're
really losing our minds we're talking a
lot of [ __ ] to each other and Tom got
sick Tom got the flu and then the day
got better from the flu he ran 13 miles
no [ __ ] the day he got better he ran 13
miles through his neighborhood through
the Hills
that's different than a treadmill 13
miles on the street is like that's real
yeah yeah
yeah we went crazy yeah and like if that
kept going imagine if we had it for like
six months we had a fitness contest for
six months and at the end of six months
you win like a million dollars yeah
you could have got a sponsor for that
easy yeah the problem is it would become
your whole life all right we would go
crazy all right and Bert would die Bert
would for sure have a heart attack or he
would just be content coming in last
like he did last time he talked a lot of
[ __ ] and came in last he did yeah
yeah
yeah it seems like it seems like a great
idea for your men like for me working
out is just for my head I don't even
give a [ __ ] I mean this body I was
naturally born with it's a gift
congratulations but my brain if I work
out man I just feel happy and if I don't
I get depressed so one of the things we
talked about Tom and I talked about
specifically was that when you do a lot
of cardio in a day like four hours of
cardio in a day he goes all the internal
chatter just goes away I go yeah there's
like there's no negative talk there's no
like anxiety and angst and I really
wonder how much of that the people walk
around with all day could be fixed with
cardio
could be fixed with like rigorous
exercise
you know and they say um they say
weightlifting helps anxiety too they say
strength training does but uh for me
it's like cardio cardio seems to put me
in this place where it just is like
whatever who gives a [ __ ] it's just like
just a really peaceful
it like balances out what's really
important to think about and worry about
versus like things are just sort of
bouncing around your head you don't know
if I should pay attention to that one or
that one and what should I freak out
about the most